there are growing indications this
morning that social media executives
will be called to testify about Russian
activity on their websites Facebook
announced last week it found about 3000
ads with messages about divisive issues
the ads were linked to Russian internet
trolls but congressional investigators
tell CBS News the revelation is likely
just the tip of the iceberg Deborah
gazes in Washington with the next steps
in this investigation Jeff good morning
good morning the top Democrat on the
Senate Intelligence Committee wants
Facebook to be more forthcoming about
this and that could mean testifying here
on Capitol Hill Senator Mark Warner
believes that the scope of Russian
activity on the social media giant was
more widespread than Facebook is
currently acknowledging but a Facebook
official says because of federal laws
and the ongoing Russia investigations
the company is limited in what it can
say but that is just one part of the
Russia investigation and in connection
with another aspect of it the Department
of Justice says it will not allow two
top FBI officials to testify about the
firing of James Comey in a letter
obtained by CBS News Justice Department
officials said that they want to protect
the integrity of Special Counsel Robert
Muller's investigation there are also
reports this morning that the son of
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn is now also under scrutiny Michael
Flynn jr. is a close business associate
of his father's and he also took a trip
to Moscow with his father back in
December of 2015
Norah all right a lot of reporting there
Jeff thank you so much